sogar bei unseren dreharbeiten treffen
wir auf ehemalige mitschüler die erben
immer noch kennen und sich mit
geräuschen über sie lustig machen
so ist es immer die junge frau plötzlich
herzlich kommt sondern wieder leute ich
war letztens wieder auf youtube
unterwegs und habe ich ein video
gefunden bei dem ich mir gedacht habe
sebastian das musst du unbedingt in
einem seiner videos schauen weil das
video an sich erst als geisteskrank
essen weil ich zweitens anhand des
videos eine sehr wichtige botschaft
rüberbringen will das video heißt
mobbing wegen zu lange haben und wir
schauen direkt rein
okay ein meter 53 ist die haarpracht von
rn fernando und seit ihrer kindheit hat
die 15 jährige ihre haare wachsen lassen
sie sind ihr ganzer stolz new york erste
ersten moment erst mal wenn ich diesen
mädchen in die augen schaue sehe ich
schon so viel über sie als personen
kennt ihr das auch leute wie schaut's
manchen leuten ins gesicht und er
versteht die sofort checkt sofort aus
dem deren leben vorgehen als prinzip
werden ich habe versteht was ich meine
aber bei ihr sehe ich sofort so die
wurde auf jeden fall schon ein paar mal
verletzt im leben so das sieht man in
den augen habe ich das gefühl aber ja
video städte wie gesagt moggi wegen zu
langen haaren und die ihre haare sind
extrem lang ein meter 53 oder so zu lang
sind manche menschen nicht durch genau
dieses markenzeichen hut herum zu einer
außenseiterin gemacht vor zwei jahren
ist sie von der schule gegangen weil sie
das mobbing nicht mehr ausgehalten hat
new york new york ich hab' ich hab doch
gesagt leute gut durchdachten peter
defekt ist ich will jetzt kein hellseher
aber wirklich schaut diese mädchen
einfach ins gesicht und ihr seht ist
sofort alter ihr seht sofort dass die
stadt richtig scheiße erlebt hat ist so
effekt aber deutlich direkt mal die
erste sache sagen leute es ist wirklich
so in was für einer kranken welt leben
wir dass ein mensch die schule wechseln
muss weil es sie bei einer schule so
schlecht geht nur weil er haare hat am
kopf die bisschen länger sind als vom
anders oder viel länger es ist so ein
krank unerhebliches merkmal bei einer
person wie lange die haare sind aber
leute werden dafür versucht hast gemobbt
dass ihr die schule wechseln müssen an
der verkommen ich konnte sie mal hierher
der aussage ich hole mal eine freundin
ab ich versuche diesen ort so knothe
street zu vermeiden
rip alter.de jockey tut mir richtig leid
wird und ich will mal für alle sagen die
diesen teil für über mich vielleicht
noch nicht kennen ich habe auch
erfahrungen der schule gemacht mit
mobbing über 23 jahre hinweg war sehr
sehr unangenehm
ich kann eins zu eins wie leighton zu
dem was sie sagt ist auch nicht lustig
aber keine ahnung zu sorgen so dass
jetzt darüber reden es ist zum beispiel
bei mir auch so weit ich will auch kein
mitleid oder sowas aber so
klassentreffen oder sowas
wiedervereinigung von der klasse nach
fünf jahren 18 also sind für mich
einfach nicht so interessant weil weil
deswegen zehn jahre
gelernt hat sie das mobbing der
mitschüler ertragender wie der kaugummi
anzahl geklebt da sieht daran gezogen
haben ist egal was unseren dreharbeiten
treffen wir auf ehemalige mitstreiter
nordjob es ist so nett dass leute wegen
sowas einfach so krass fertig gemacht
werden und das schlimmste und muss man
wirklich sagen das allerschlimmste sind
eigentlich nicht mal die erwachsenen das
ist zumindest meine überzeugung ich
finde die schlimmsten wird solche sachen
sind kinder und jugendliche es ist so
brutal digger alter wenn du einmal als
einziger der klasse nicht die richtigen
marken klamotten anders so keine also zu
dumm einfach es ist ein bisschen anderes
logo auf dem schuh drauf dann wirst du
gehörst gift und ich finde dass
geisteskrankheit dafür sogar bei unseren
dreharbeiten treffen wir auf ehemalige
mitschüler die erben immer noch kennen
und sich mit geräuschen über sie lustig
machen
wieso habt wisst ihr was leute es ist
auch wirklich ein fact finde ich es ist
auch perfekt geworden ist dass jedes mal
zustimmen meistens sind die leute die
auf anderen rumhacken wegen so kleinen
unterschieden die die selbst am
unsichersten sind von allen gericht die
schiffs haben dass einer sima
konfrontiert deswegen geht ja in der
offensive und das ist so leute die sich
direkt einfach so
das ist so schön dass die menschheit
braucht sowas nicht wirklich die haben
einfach eine stelle verdient die bunten
sitzen immer noch tief und wovon sie da
wusste sie ihre peiniger ertragen wenn
sie das sofort den klägern also kleiner
bastard kindern die alle gleich aussehen
da einfach rein klatschen aber die sind
alle gleich aus allen jogginghose oder
so wahrscheinlich kommt mit kompletten
und nike oder adidas und denken sie die
krassesten damit der kunde also sorry
leute und ich hab ein bisschen alkohol
bin aber das wäre darüber jetzt willst
so wache über dieses thema ja klar ich
musste einfach von der schule gehen weil
es mir nicht mehr gut ging
der ist wegen schalter ganz kurz ein
fact leute den gleichen taschenrechner
habe ich auch denn hier warte warte
warte warte stockt ihr leute wir wir
haben den gleichen taschenrechner
besitzt im selben boot ob ich bin auf
deiner seite und deswegen hat er
mittlerweile zu hause privat unterricht
und lernen kleine große unterstützung
hat sie von ihrer familie die zum
kranksein hallo steht ihre mutter
[Gelächter]
einfach alle in der familie aber so ein
wettstreit wer so die längsten haare
haben kann man aber okay batterie
versieht 153 oder sortieren die der ganz
links steht oder die große sie dann
zusammen haben die drei frauen ihre
haare darunter gehen
mein gott es ist schon außergewöhnlich
muss man auch sagen aber es ist
unglaublich eigentlich dass leute sobald
sie ihr gewissen aus der reihe tanzen
sofort zack sofort gibt's sofort auf die
frist ist es zu krass eigentlich oder
ich liebe langes haar
ich finde es wahnsinnig weiblich ich
habe es bei den mädchen wachsen lassen
also ich muss ganz ehrlich sagen dass
das kann ich aber auch so sagen also
mein persönliches schönheitsideal ist
jetzt nicht haare von einem meter
fünfzig länger zu haben aber leute auch
wenn sich mein ding ist nun wirklich
jeder sofort zugestimmt
echte leben treffen wenn ich sage sagen
krass was du erlebt was soll ich sofort
dass ich auf jeden fall weiter durch
machst du dein ding auf alle anderen
leute wir haben es seit der kindheit
wachsen und wachsen lassen
aber auch geisteskrank wie kommen wir
jetzt für mich also ein punkt an wo man
sagt ja ihr sitzt so ein eines morgens
waisenkinder die mädels waren drei jahre
alt oder setzen sie beim frühstück und
dann soll ich also lasst einfach mal
alle die haare geisteskrank lang wachsen
lassen es lauern überall kleine gefahren
das aufstehen mit wallender mähne kann
zur herausforderung werden
und da kann es schon mal ziehen und auch
beim morgen wieder auf meinen paaren
sitzen beim aufstehen und mir die haare
ausreißen gar keinen bock mehr reformen
ist sie wirklich so ist es so als hätte
er ein bisschen ist es so als hätte dir
irgendwie keine ahnung hinten im gürtel
so eine eineinhalb meter lange schnur
die zieht ihr euch so hinter euch her da
muesste du musst ja sogar aufpassen wenn
die aus der bahn rausgeht und einfach
mitgezogen bei einsteigen ins auto
sollte man den starken wenn es unbedingt
berücksichtigt wirklich finster wort
alter diese wirklich cool rapunzel mal
schauen wie rechts in die mitte der mit
dem blonden dingern spitzen kann weiß
niemand sagt benny die tür zuschlägt der
die reise selbst die haare die hängt in
der tür fest die macht ihr das geschenk
ist ins auto rein und dann holt ihr aber
so dass das triggert meine aus
was war das denn jetzt kann man nicht
hochladen nicht auf youtube wo viele
menschen zuschauen wie oc die am und die
sowas nicht sein geld seit ihrem schule
austritt fühlt sich aber noch nicht mehr
ausgeschlossen und einsamen und dass sie
sich mit ihren freunden extra verabreden
muss statt sie automatisch in der klasse
zu treffen findet sie nicht schlimm
das hat das original das original
rapunzel es ist auch kein zufall safe um
die vortag gesagt ok kommen okay lasst
mal auch wirklich die rapunzel szene
machen du gehst auf den balkon und wir
wohl noch irgendwie zäh und steht ihren
schopf hätte sie nie geopfert um sich
anzupassen
ich habe immer sogar extra so gelassen
um mir zu beweisen dass ich so sein kann
wie ich will
ich feiere ich feiere ich feiere ich
feiere ich feiere ich feiere ich krass
richtig richtiger balls muss man sagen
also sie ist ja auch noch jung ich
meinen sie geht noch in die schule
organisieren so und dass man in dem
alter schon sagt er weißt du was kann
ihr alle hier alle in meiner klasse 30
leute wollten sich platt machen wollten
keine apa/red vorbeck ihr wollt mich
und dann zu sagen müssen was ich scheiße
für euch so ich gehe auf eine
privatschule und ich dass meine haare
trotzdem lang
das ist da das ist rapunzel bleibt das
so meint dazu die leute wenn ihr auch
gegen mobbing seite und schreibe sondern
die kommentare checkt hier ein
vorgeschlagenes video aber nicht hier um
einen knall
ich bin erst mal raus was gut